back address okay Richard can't buy
psychobabble and we'll play the game
with the stocks account what remains of
a dispatch I can have such as like what
is the bird game anyway
I've heard a lot of things about this
game specifically that it's like a white
girl simulator Oh anyway let's just get
started I can't even I am excited I'm
alright
hello okay I guess [ __ ] up my wrist
but that's okay you know everyone talk
about my wrestle days come on I don't
this isn't going to make sense to you
and I'm sorry guys you can start at the
beginning to show you where to start but
okay let's start the house sure sure
okay
I'm [ __ ] stuck in the woods again you
know my tonic is [ __ ] second Oh what
I um okay let's just gotta here until I
was 11 but I wasn't allowed inside half
the room as a parlor and store as a [ __ ]
I lived in a [ __ ] house
um hello flat oh I'm mailbox can you
imagine if that's the house you know
talkin for every opportunity to [ __ ]
mail the one day they kill themselves
okay that's a yeah
I don't right now my job in your locker
bills from seven years ago marked urgent
open immediately I can't
that's what that is I don't have any
bells
we don't have about my brother Lewis
it's you know okay Brad Louis with that
gotcha
I had my way back okay oh my god oh my
god how do you [ __ ] run in this game
no one else and I get my mother left me
keep it didn't tell me whatever lock
thanks well obviously that I'd know or
she thought the mystery be enough to
bring you back okay helpful
I guess kiss have to be challenged and
I'm like give them everything and it'll
be spoiled okay
I just god that's right ask
- gasps the truth is even after I
inherited the house
what's the truck I never thought I'd
come back to it back yeah I know I had
questions about my family don't need a
house know the answers to
yeah [ __ ] if I hope I'll be in that
[ __ ] i claret those bedrooms available a
path in uncomfortably silent okay is if
they're allowed to say something but
never do okay fine okay I can I'll
basketball game get all basketball again
what a beautiful lifestyle [ __ ] I look
crazy what the construction probably
like I remembered it the way I've been
dreaming about it
yep big house this indeed is a white
girl simulator that's for sure
Oh what the [ __ ] is that okay
my cables been crazy things and they got
money at Saoirse as a child the house
made me uncomfortable in a way I
couldn't put in towards huh as a 17 year
old I knew exactly those words were I
was afraid of foul brown and they got me
going through the back you know so was
how you getting out all right that's all
too familiar answering our good doctor
or used to be a lot easier when I was 11
silence okay I got some generic you know
their stuff and uh what is that
no no no the Power had been turned off
tonight you left okay they left in a
rush there's time in years
what for so many years why I felt like I
was home oh uh yeah I'll [ __ ] Matt
that's for sure
look five mounted in the family they
were just memories of one okay
Edith that's me typical white girl Eddie
um Eddie guess ETA lady as low as ever
there he's [ __ ] croaked I guess I
thought hang on honey it's on Batman
haven't seen you in years I was sad for
I love brother
Edith's son grandson great-grandson to
AAA okay it's a shame a lot of bucks
someone as well learn Chinese oh god Ken
like how only one restaurant would
deliver to our house so we had Chinese a
lot okay not too bad
or how after Lewis started working at
the cannery we all got sick of eating
salmon
except our cat Molly I was balling the
table was still a wreck from the night
you left I think [ __ ] run so quickly
that's in here yeah okay okay
fresh sure my mom was the only one of us
who could imagine great-grandma Edie
living in a nursing home
yeah why do you want to leave this place
please don't know why people on their
books I love it
nothing in the house looked at normal
there was just too much of it like I
smile too many teeth he's in the
fireplace had a story Edie told me the
bricks came from the original house
after it sank okay um and I feel like
metaphors I guess I just talk indexing
my not good
hello it's low okay mama always told me
to stay out of the basement so I wasn't
too surprised when I key didn't fit okay
Barbara [ __ ] not one of these
right grandpa's been built music box for
Barbara along with the rent of the house
ah okay chefs we scared Edie told me
once that every Finch who ever lived is
buried somewhere in the library
it's [ __ ] marbeth uh you know people
say some crazy [ __ ] sometimes my mom
wasn't much of an optimist but she never
stopped believing that my brother Milton
was alive rahmel times is yeah a lot of
things got left behind in the whirlwind
of pet last night what happened last
night
not that I know I guess if I could catch
n again I guess not I go upstairs
no I pay well oh what a picture after
Milton disappeared mom sealed up all the
bedrooms then Edie retaliated and
drilled peep holes
okay how they going on there Calvin is
he dad my grandpa Sam spent seven years
sharing a room with his dead brother
Calvin okay
Cavanaugh Sam any kind of cool place
Greg right he lived one year as a kid I
just assumed every house had people some
sealed rooms you weren't allowed inside
of I guess Gregory [ __ ] I lived in the
rest and that's fine I guess I'm a fan
and Eddie and I was at their [ __ ] dad
the last time I was in Edith's seniors
room I was ten and she was painting my
portrait okay okay look fine
that's in here Shen's for thought man
let me check out Molly's room
well I [ __ ] died tiny is all he
always seemed like a girl I could
imagine being friends with if she hadn't
died in 1947 okay yeah sad remember that
I spent a lot of time playing in great
uncle Walters rooms Walter I think my
mom sometimes regretted not sealing it
up I'm not Lois told me there were
secret passages that I never believed in
20,000 legs under us a lot saying fess
that the club doesn't fit you a mouse I
click that Jess okay house my mom was
really good at keeping secrets
well I shot uh my mom had been afraid of
this Norma what is this polish with no
paintings on the wall it was clear my
brother Milton had been here before me
no pad you like kiddo reading this
maybe it sounds like I had a plan
[Music]
okay I was a piss jar did you piss on us
okay let's check this out he had no idea
what was behind that door oh yeah rounds
around room to room I say just like I
had no idea where all this was gonna
lead
yeah where's this lady at Molly's room
okay
I grew up looking at Molly's room
through the peephole drop off is that
hot as hell okay Smalley's terrible had
a tiny bedroom would it's only even
tinier gerbil cage holy [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] up you know five people
they're graduating so fast out there I
had spent a lot of time here okay what
the [ __ ] of that
December 13 1947 dear diary I'll be gone
soon but I wanted to tell somebody about
what's going to happen
it started with Madison mystery doctor
at dinner I woke up I'm starving so I
looked around for something to eat
it's a terrible oh it's one careless
driver I didn't mind it so I can
disgusting it's fine I guess
mom can I come out now
I think Russian what's an accent I'm so
bad accent shall I drink you bad Oh huh
I thought about being Christopher but I
hope that all right can I guess not bad
I kept eating and eating
no but my son saw that miracle gel again
okay okay a lot of things that night
okay you know that's the grossest [ __ ]
how's that noise and we are yeah well
pest I gotta get my piss on this I hope
I go camping outside my window good oh
boy it was going back to her nest I
brush I reach that bar dot batshit crazy
white girl you like that crazy
I was a cat okay get this batch Olli
mister I tried to get quiet as a bird is
really scared at Christmas not [ __ ] like
that again I get yeah let's gonna didn't
even look at me
oh shut up my god I pasted it look at me
well I guess they're still building
right now
oh you look on right all right book on
your back
yeah but I could tell she was getting
really tired returned with her bro now I
was up in a big tree
I promised dad I wouldn't climb it
anymore all I cared about was eating at
mama but I gobbled her alright that
[ __ ] and suddenly I was an owl
nibbling okay typical like elegance
fantasies other than getting out of
poverty
okay get this [ __ ] I got Jeff that's
not even Trotter is it for us to harbor
Walton up and I did
st. yeah and the others like dear Shep
I'm gonna eat a mama rabbit you're going
for the sock and all a lie I got you
with that
just like I got your daughter here I
started choking but I couldn't stop what
happened sometimes enough I'll shut
that's normal you know this is normal
I'm safe fine this is how a girl Brady
says I like holy [ __ ] into the ocean
yeah that was hungry this [ __ ] what is
it
are you bench show cheese do you feel
we'll give it to you
oh yeah I could tell you're under
stressful but you know it's tough
economy ready go ready go when I open it
roll what am I
I'm a monster I smell people I'm on a
monster god Yemenite I stepped out of a
phenomenon play me feel free let it
upset you sigh alright that's us say it
[Music]
not my name just after NECA I wanted to
stop also shot guy standing alarm
yes all right all right
what if you have the half point girls
insatiable it's some slump a stretch a
good smell
what is I got smell [ __ ] I go to the
toilet
uh yeah bag back ah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
toilet make myself a bench with a fetish
ah yeah batches oh you're out of my
white door I want a knockoff can't you
say that I'm well you're about to get
[ __ ] up I can't because Noah stop so
10 I go once it starts like I'm a dancer
I'm a dancer
I can make stomach started growling okay
that's side
[Music]
okay I glad this guy was gone that's
normal
very glad to have children one day I'm
not sure if I believed all of that but
I'm sure Edie would have alright oh that
one's gone because obviously I'm Seattle
a couple ocean anyways oh that's kind of
it let her it's almost a sock advantage
again this could be obvious later but my
mom never told me any of these stories
he would have but mom didn't like
bringing up the past so when we adopted
a stray kitten she was the one who named
it molly was that Polly [ __ ] eleven
outdoors now I spend a lot of time in
great-grandma Edie's room ain't
day-lewis died a week before we left
but Edie had already started to
memorialize him what Louis died from out
that 1937 sunidhi told people that Ben
was killed by a dragon she could also
have said he was building a dragon
shaped slide that collapse
oh [ __ ] I was outside she didn't [ __ ]
a people just dropping dead from
everything
Walter gasps a lot of people on the
phone just like a museum
for 500 years the finches have been
famous throughout Norway for their
fortune and misfortune Odin Finch buries
the latest victims family curse his wife
ingerborg and their newborn son Johan on
menu 7th 1937 he set sail with his
family and his house hoping to lead
visit in the water oh he's taking his
house but 40-foot waves off the coast of
Washington send the house and Odin to
Odin's daughter Edie with husband's been
and baby Molly step ashore on their new
home orcas island Odin Finch is the
first to be buried in a new family
cemetery walk the daughter Edie is
already dreaming of a new Finch house so
she's like the first one every pound
with this family it goes back a long
ways
that's right I got out of here how the
[ __ ] right this is another door even in
their 90's
sometimes et seemed a lot younger than
my mother oh this was a foggy trace
grandpa Sam's first wife Kay left on the
house was the pink bathroom it was a
pretty big trace yeah I guess we're
traveling through the [ __ ] story
again there's a second unless Batman
there's a secret in this bathroom it's
in the last place you would look it
isn't in the cupboard
it's hidden in this book check clever
betcha huh yeah that's right I guess I'm
I'm a Calvin this death then gave Sam an
old camera he'd refurbished he never put
it down
I guess I get weird again melt sad what
happened him again
oh they never found it
that's am I missing Isaac papers check
I knew grandpa Sam had a twin and that
he never talked about him when Gomes
laid off I didn't like history any more
than my mom did this is the one that he
lived with I guess Kevin how I want to
remember my brother by fanfic the thing
I remember is that when he made up his
mind that was it
my brother said he died before you in my
mushroom and he did yeah good for him
stick him to his work at Barbara's
funeral
we swore we'd never be afraid of him and
he wasn't I think Calvin always wanted
to fly it's all broken why can't I do
this yeah
does that day he finally made up his
mind to do it
wept again I doubt oh I going around is
impossible I said he'd gone for that 36
thing maybe if I hadn't said that
[Music]
- you betcha
and maybe should still be here right let
me tell yourself that is the first role
of doing [ __ ] like that is to make sure
you got a lot already made of his mind
[Music]
that's what I want to remember about my
brother
this guy is correct yes
Megiddo bro I got a shirt in front and
you did
[Music]
okay sure American arrow
[Music]
Calvin's story felt strangely familiar
when I was younger I remember trying to
do the exact same thing
ciao by the chair American arrow after
the funeral
didi ripped off Calvin's half the room
is dark forth Sam mom if I'd grab the
salmon listed at 18 and never set foot
in the room again this
ah very cool though I'm aware that they
can all just like snake each other
forever you know
[Music]
Holloway passages were a pretty tight
fit they'd obviously been built for
smaller hands and bellies Fabri growing
up I always thought of Barbara as a
child star
I never thought about how hard it must
have been for her afterwards nice
decorations and holy [ __ ] I only books
these people right I guess there's no in
fact out of all the stories people wrote
about Barbara's death I'm surprised
Edie saved this one so no knows how she
died oh sure oh yeah
inspired by a most unfortunate former
economist they surprised angry at
Barbara Lynch
selectin why is he so angry a child star
Barbara was famous for her screen now at
16 she was all washed up husband you
know lucky print she's been asked to
perform her signature scream at a local
convention for monster burger look ahead
to the box art lady scream having aged
we're getting better has especially the
right motivation her biggest fan and
current boyfriend Rick was about to
demonstrate when Mark oh that was a
great scream
he joins Barbara
keep slippin to a table saw I had to be
rushed to the emergency room
so Barbara that's not babysitting her
youngest brother Walter okay convention
I'm back my skin's out haha okay I'm
hearing frustrations but I'm not hearing
terror what if I tried the gang of
hoodlums and Halloween masks have been
terrorizing
Orcas Island tonight police are urging
residents to the basement you're right
also I loved your delivery on that why
have your basement door locked because
my dad likes making puzzles and secret
passages there's a key hit in the music
box
ah secret just keep winding and winding
come until finally he pops out shell
cycle they'll be back in a sec my three
minutes late huh Rick packing to attack
is that help Barbara went to look for
him right on - she reached what I'm
using oh yeah it's a wreck where are ya
shows also guy mixed clash and imagine
them left
[ __ ] this [ __ ] again real
now I'll play with no fee you know the
gangs leader is the infamous hook man
killer dr. Carl handled hi yeah a killer
[ __ ] you I that's right that's just okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] this matchup [ __ ] him up I'll
[ __ ] kill barb relax
I was just trying to scare you to help
you find your screen that's our first
matchup i playin i your yet
Yashin a fact furious all I'm getting
from you now is that you're hurt and
confused and get on my face you [ __ ]
[ __ ] is kondeh barb have you seen my
other grudge discussion we feel homey
and you I sleep watching that link like
and I look [ __ ] watching Walter I
guess he's fun dad to me alright that
just fair to be [ __ ] up by Barbara
Finch I play ie play nugget are you in a
[ __ ] huh I reflected that too fast
for you [ __ ] eka eka Epke ah someone's
messing with my skates huh and I'll say
Alice got ours a little [ __ ]
I'll say if I betcha laugh
Orcas Island police describes a man as
six feet tall with a steel hook for a
hand
residents are urged a lock all doors and
windows and notify the police of any
potential of us there there yes that's
nice a nice fabric test
tada [ __ ] man and that's uterus crashing
man I [ __ ] you up that's that's it
sure I want to get him in here there's
got to be another way out of here
two doctors no mate let me tell you
something in my house I have blocks of
it inside on the outside because I like
to keep a man that sure story white oh I
like I like to watch it slowly stop
breathing like that I'd like to save let
me get down there I want to lick his
face and look his tears to lick his face
hey nice that match okay come on I like
your tears [ __ ] not right
where are they now see you left a
[ __ ] mess oh she wash all right what
Samaras speak Japanese thank you I'm
inside the house sure I got two [ __ ]
to cut up it's the first date here's a
second the second session scram
what's she hiding it's not that much but
she loves herself and she saw what kind
of monsters they were they're haters
realize what was about to happen
what is it like a morning like a fox
okay
she hadn't taste fresh start by
unfortunately so did her friends of
course the police blamed it all on
already who disappeared and Little
Walter hiding under his bed the whole
time he pops I picked I hope we ll shut
music box is all the other sound of her
so her boyfriend soccer took a year I
was high end Jax was there she's all
[ __ ] up okay Edie told me all Barbara
wanted was to be remembered as I started
that comic was maybe what et saw was a
happy ending okay how am I gonna [ __ ]
flip through the wall again about that I
have a breath I and I can is a crotchal
there yeah I got another way I guess now
I know why mom doesn't like me playing
with the music box
mm-hmm we get that [ __ ] rig stuff
right now whenever people ask me about
my family
the first thing they always want to know
about is Barbara that's up there my [ __ ]
up there you keep this music box [ __ ] is
true this guy loves walk it that's for
sure okay my hair is that okay
all right wine ass that's my message I'm
on tip gotta go I guess
okay saving [ __ ]
okay okay what's so cool about this
place
I just had a man cave and I guess he did
loitering sounds that thread onto the
basement was off limits unless I wanted
another tetanus shot where he saw a
second hand off of me I guess I thought
Edie sneak down to the basement ones
carrying packages okay I thought maybe
she was hiding presents it turned out
she was hiding a lot more than that
and it's people if I can say so
[Music]
[ __ ] the dark in here I remember asking
mom about where Walter gone the [ __ ]
they buried on her she said after
Barbara died he got as far away as he
could assure the pattern all these
stories I think it's that none of us
have gotten very far
oh it [ __ ] if I can live down here holy
[ __ ] he [ __ ] aged - goodbye everyone
I can't believe I've been down here for
30 what's the far on that first day
after the shaking stuff I didn't think
I'd survive these lots of shakin but
after a few days I settled into a
routine that's what kept me sane and
even [ __ ] invited my dad having a
schedule living for today what I always
expected to be dead tomorrow
[Music]
but if you wait long you see that even a
monster on the other side of the door
starts to feel normal
I just traitor fun almost friendly
subway and then one day everything just
[Music]
stopped whatever that thing was it was
gone
maybe you got tired of waiting
I thought the Train and maybe I just got
tired of being afraid all right
hey like a patient it's been a week now
the longest in 30 years
I'm done waiting I have to leave while I
still can we check place out were quick
and theyá--
I'll wash up Rahzel alright I used to
look up some more pages you know self a
call set up right like must either you
get that could go oh if you guys saw
that J Cole a Barmes grape jelly I know
it's out there somewhere that's out
there sky thing is [ __ ] option bar
room rec moley
Molly my [ __ ] a terrible food Calvin
[ __ ] the side of this hole on the sly
away but I need to stop living the same
day even if it kills me
bet your [ __ ] all whatever's out there
yeah yeah I'm not that you know I'm
ready for it
I'm going to appreciate all of it
especially the food I don't mind if I
only have a year left a man I have a
yell I want now for a single week I'd be
happy for you
I can already imagine the Sun
[Music]
holy [ __ ] did he just [ __ ] dive I'm a
train if he [ __ ] actually died what
train after being in here for so long
Walter died when I was six
no [ __ ] way I can't believe my mom
never told me he was down here that is
some [ __ ] up [ __ ]